das virus verbreitet sich immer weiter
in deutschland speziell in sachsen und
im süden von brandenburg arbeiten immer
mehr krankenhäuser am limit abgas
software in dieselautos war illegal das
urteil des europäischen gerichtshofs hat
auswirkungen auf die rechte von
millionen autobesitzer 250 jahre alt und
immer noch modern die musikwelt feiert
den geburtstag von ludwig van beethoven
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und abend hinein geben
sie uns knapp 20 minuten für den
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag norbert könig ist hier und
hat nachher den sport ja genannt
ab dem 27 dezember will deutschland die
ersten bürger gegen das corona virus
impfen so denn alles glatt läuft mit der
zulassung
gleichzeitig wird die aktuelle situation
immer drängender und damit beginnen wir
heute abend binnen 24 stunden meldet das
robert koch institut aufgrund von
positivtests mittlerweile 26 1923 kroner
neuinfektionen und dabei fehlen sogar
noch und 3500 fälle aus baden
württemberg wegen technischer probleme
somit wurden in deutschland rechnerisch
mehr als 30.000 neue infektionen an
einem tag registriert das gab es noch
nie
besonders stark betroffen ist sachsen
zuletzt lag der sieben tage währt dort
mehr als doppelt so hoch wie im
bundesschnitt
in vielen sächsischen kliniken werden
die intensivbetten knapp aus dresden
cornelia schiemenz kaum noch ein freies
bett
die intensiv plätze sind zu 98 prozent
belegt nachzulesen auf dem
internetauftritt der stadt dresden sowie
in der uniklinik der landeshauptstadt
sieht es vielerorts in sachsen aus der
freistaat ist an den grenzen seiner
medizinischen kapazitäten und wir haben
kliniken die haben jetzt 30 40 infektion
beim pflegepersonal zb und können gar
keine betten zusätzlich betragen
der ministerpräsident längst ein
getriebener getrieben von immer höheren
corona zahlen dass die landesregierung
im hintergrund daran arbeitet
möglicherweise gemeinden abzuriegeln
dementiert kretzschmar heute nicht
wirklich
man müsse die nächsten 10 bis 14 tage
abwarten
ich möchte ihnen sagen dass es dazu
keine beschlüsse
und auch keine entscheidungen gibt und
in der nächsten zeit geben wird sechs
der zehn größten krone hotspots liegen
in sachsen
die landesregierung versucht zusätzliche
betten bereit zu stellen zum beispiel in
reha kliniken
viele menschen haben trotzdem angst wie
hier auf den straßen in pirna ich hatte
wirklich angst noch ob ich noch
verhandelt werden könnte wenn ich schwer
erkranken würde diese sorge habe ich
schon aber die erste was diese leisten
die pflegepersonal dass die leute
leisten das ist ja das ist der blanke
wahnsinn
und so arbeitet das medizinische
personal in sachsen längst am limit das
nachbarland brandenburg meldet
inzwischen ähnliche zustände vor allem
im süden sei die lage ausgesprochen
ernst unter gewinnen in den süden von
brandenburg nämlich nach senftenberg
nicola albrecht es dort für uns halo
nicola was hören sie denn von den
krankenhäusern dort also die lage hier
ist so prekär dass das land brandenburg
heute andere bundesländer schon um hilfe
gebeten hat patienten von hier
aufzunehmen die klinik hier die klinik
niederlausitz vor der ich stehe
praktiziert das bereits seit mehr als
einer woche werden hier täglich
patienten verlegt zum beispiel mit dem
hubschrauber nach berlin geflogen um
überhaupt hier noch die versorgung
aufrecht erhalten zu können
das problem ist nicht nur die stetig
nachkommenden patienten die korona
infizierten das virus macht ja auch
nicht vor ärzten und pflegepersonal halt
mittlerweile haben sich hier viele
infiziert und deswegen ist der
personalmangel also auch noch eine
zusätzliche belastung das klinikum hat
sogar zu einer ungewöhnlichen maßnahme
gegriffen und einen hilferuf gestartet
so dass seit einer woche hier
bürgerinnen und bürger freiwillig
mithelfen mit und ohne medizinische
vorkenntnisse um den klinikbetrieb
aufrecht zu erhalten das problem ist
einfach die hohe incidents im landkreis
die liegt aktuell bei 570 und davon
kommt man nicht runter und so haben sich
landräte hier schon gedanken gemacht und
überlegen nun vielleicht in kürze den
katastrophenfall aus zu rufen mediziner
mit denen ich gesprochen habe würden das
durchaus begrüßen denn das würde ihnen
die möglichkeit geben die lage besser zu
managen
live aus senftenberg nicola albrecht
herzlichen dank unmittelbar nach
weihnachten diesen termin hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister im auge für
den impfstart in deutschland und in der
eu
wenn mit der zulassung alles wie geplant
läuft aber auch dann gibt es jede menge
herausforderungen das vielleicht größte
problem erst mal ist viel zu wenig
impfstoff vorhanden christina kaiser
berichtet die impfzentren stehen bereit
doch bis es hier richtig losgeht ist
noch ein logistischer kraftakt fällig
derzeit rechnet man mit 400.000
impfdosen für deutschland die werden
nach der eu zulassung noch durch das
paul ehrlich institut geprüft und dann
erst entsprechend der bevölkerungszahl
an die 16 bundesländer verteilt die
organisation der impfungen ist
ländersache
sie folgen dabei der empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission die
gesundheitsminister sparen morgen
unterschreiben will
unser ziel ist es insgesamt zuerst
diejenigen zu schützen die über 80
jährig sind die und die in alten- und
pflegeheim leben oder arbeiten um in die
besonders verwundbare zuerst zu schützen
mit diesem sehr wirksamen impfstoff alle
anderen werden darüber unterrichtet wann
sie dran sind wenn sie dran sind
los gehts voraussichtlich am 27
dezember in den heimen dies erfolgt
durch mobile teams der impfzentren hilfe
bekommen sie von den krankenkassen und
der kassenärztlichen vereinigung
finanziell und organisatorisch erst im
nächsten schritt sollen weitere
risikogruppen zur impfung eingeladen
werden
solange aber der impfstoff noch knapp
ist und stark gekühlt werden muss
braucht man diese einladung für eine
impfung im impfzentrum so soll auch ein
geordneter und zügiger verbrauch des
impfstoffs gewährleistet werden
viele bundesländer wollen deshalb briefe
verschicken und die terminvergabe
zentral regeln
das genaue vorgehen wird gerade erst
noch abgestimmt im laufe der zeit sollen
dann auch hausärztinnen selbst impfen
können
bis also weite teile der bevölkerung
geimpft sind wird es noch viele monate
dauern
kroner hotspot altenheim wie können wir
die bewohner besser schützen das fragt
zdf heute live um 19 30 die leiterin der
caritas altenheime in münchen
und auch sie können ihre fragen stellen
auf zdf heute youtube und facebook
auch der französische präsident emanuel
makro hat corona er habe symptome und
sich daraufhin testen lassen heißt es
aus dem élyséepalast
makro habe sich in quarantäne begeben
und will von zu hause aus arbeiten
ende vergangener woche hatte sich makro
auf dem eu-gipfel in brüssel unter
anderem mit bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel getroffen
sie sei jetzt aber negativ getestet
worden sagt ein sprecher
in den usa breitet sich das corona virus
in immer größerem tempo aus in absoluten
zahlen ist kein land der welt stärker
betroffen
zuletzt wurden in 24 stunden fast eine
viertelmillion neue infektionen gezählt
3656 menschen sind an oder mit dem virus
gestorben beides höchststände
entsprechend sind viele krankenhäuser
überlastet und währenddessen läuft seit
montag die impfkampagne aus washington
berichtet peter theisen auch die
krankenhäuser in den usa melden neue
traurige höchststände 113000 menschen
liegen mit cobit im krankenhaus
besonders dramatisch die lage in
kalifornien
wir arbeiten hier alle bis an die grenze
der belastbarkeit stunde um stunde ohne
pause die mitarbeiter machen zwei
schichten hintereinander um es irgendwie
hinzukriegen
doch es gibt auch hoffnung sie ist die
erste altenheimbewohnerin die sich in
florida vor laufenden kameras gegen
kuwait impfen lässt wäre lieb 88 jahre
alt ich seite hoch erfreut sich immer
mehr man kann erkennen dass diese
impfstoffe sicher und außerordentlich
wirksam
bereits am nächsten dienstag will sich
der designierte us-präsident impfen
lassen
ich will mich nicht vordrängeln aber
zeigen dass der impfstoff sicher ist und
deshalb werde ich mich in aller
öffentlichkeit impfen lassen doch klar
ist auch die usa brauchen viel mehr
impfstoff um der grassierenden pandemie
herr zu werden
die nachfrage ist viel höher als das was
geliefert werden kann ein herausfordern
doch auch hier könnte es schon bald
fortschritte geben die oberste
arzneimittelbehörde berät derzeit über
eine notfall zulassung des moderner
impfstoffs der hat einen großen vorteil
gegenüber dem von biontech der ja bei
minus 70 grad gelagert und transportiert
werden muss der von moderner kann
hingegen über einen längeren zeitraum in
einem normalen kühlschrank lagern auch
in russland wird corona wirtschaft und
gesundheitssystem leiden und
entsprechend hat dieses thema auch viel
raum eingenommen
bei der jahrespressekonferenz von
präsident wladimir putin die jedes jahr
geradezu zelebriert wird in den
russischen medien
weiteres wichtiges thema die vorwürfe im
fall des vergifteten kreml kritikers
alexej nawalny aus moskau berichtet mein
kollege christian sen
es dauert ein bisschen bis wladimir
putin richtig sitzt gemütlich darf es
schon sein
bei der langen putin show der präsident
ist per video aus einer corona sicheren
residenz zugeschaltet journalistinnen
und journalisten sitzenden insgesamt
sieben pressezentrum fragen aus
nowosibirsk aus sankt petersburg oder
wladiwostok ein zentrales thema
natürlich corona kein gesundheitssystem
auf der welt war vorbereitet auf eine
pandemie diesen ausmaßes im vergleich
damit was in der welt passiert hat sich
unser system natürlich als effizienter
erwiesen
eine medizinerin sieht das anders sie
erzählt von problemen von anrufen aus
dem call center patienten aus den
regionen berichten wie sie mehr als eine
woche auf einen krankenwagen warten
mussten oder von fehlenden corona tests
und frustrierten ärzten thema auch der
fall navalny und die neuen recherchen
russische geheimdienste seien
verantwortlich für die vergiftung putin
streitet ab nennt navalny bewusst nicht
beim namen bezeichnet ihn als patientin
der berliner klinik der von us
geheimdiensten unterstützt werde
wenn das stimmt ist das interessant dann
müssen ihnen die geheimdienste natürlich
unter die lupe nehmen
aber das heißt nicht dass sie ihn
vergiften müssen wer braucht ihn
wenn diese dienste wollten hätten sie
die mission vollendet putin wiederholt
noch die vorwürfe deutschland behindere
die aufklärung warum russland noch keine
ermittlungen eingeleitet habe erklärt
putin nicht auch nicht nach viereinhalb
stunden pressekonferenz um den
milliardenschweren bilanzskandal beim
finanzdienstleister wirecard ging es
heute im untersuchungsausschuss des
bundestages unter anderem mit ex
verteidigungsminister karl theodor zu
guttenberg der betonte einen derartigen
betrug habe man nicht erahnen können
trotz presseberichten damals zu
guttenberg hatte als berater im
kanzleramt für wirecard geworben
2009 10 hatte sich kanzlerin merkel bei
einer china-reise für wirecard
eingesetzt das unternehmen ist
inzwischen insolvent
dieselautos abgasreinigung software mit
diesen themen beschäftigen wir uns seit
jahren auch vor gerichten
jetzt kommt ein neues urteil des
europäischen gerichtshofs dazu danach
darf die abgasreinigung nur unter
strengen voraussetzungen abgeschaltet
werden
das könnte auswirkungen haben auf
millionen älterer diesel wie felix
zimmermann berichtet auch im jahre 2020
fahren in deutschland millionen diesel
fahrzeuge die den grenzwert für giftiges
stickstoffoxid auf der straße um ein
vielfaches überschreiten
dies liegt unter anderem daran dass die
motorsteuerung in vielen dieselautos so
programmiert ist dass die abgasreinigung
schon bei in deutschland völlig üblichen
temperaturen etwa unter 15 grad
gedrosselt oder sogar deaktiviert wird
die autohersteller sind der ansicht
diese sogenannten thermo fenster seien
legal das abschalten notwendig um den
motor vor beschädigungen zu schützen
doch der ort hatte heute das argument
motorschutz greift nur in ausnahmefällen
eine richtung lässt sich nicht damit
rechtfertigen dass sie den motor vor
verschleiß oder verschmutzung schützen
sie ist nur zulässig wenn sie vom
plötzlichen montag schäden schützt die
zu einer konkreten gefahr beim fahren
führen die automobilindustrie behauptet
das urteil bringe wenig neues er hat
aber auch festgestellt dass das was wir
seit fünf jahren wissen nämlich dass die
verbesserung des emissionsverhalten auf
prüfständen illegal ist und das wird
auch nicht mehr gemacht
doch es geht gar nicht um die frage ob
die automobilindustrie jetzt rechtmäßig
handelt sondern was mit den bereits
zugelassenen autos mit thermo fenster
passiert die deutsche umwelthilfe
fordert konsequenzen
das kap hat bundesamt muss nun eine
amtliche stilllegung dieser fahrzeuge
das sind mehrere millionen dieser pkw
verfügen oder eben anordnen dass es
einen austausch der betrügerischen nicht
funktionierenden abgasreinigung durch
neue funktionierende katalysatoren gibt
das bundesverkehrsministerium sieht
keinen handlungsbedarf das kraftfahrt
bundesamt habe abschalt einrichtungen
rechtmäßig zugelassen
die behörden werden ein rückruf also
nicht freiwillig anordnen
doch es ist gut möglich dass gerichte
wegen des urteils die politik bei
zwingen millionenfach diesen fahrzeuge
zurückzurufen der diese kunde könnte
dabei zum großen verlierer werden
so und jetzt feiern wir geburtstag in
der sendung der jubilar ein genie ein
besessener ein meister der klassik und
zugleich ein popstar denn wirklich jeder
kennt seine musik
die rede ist natürlich von ludwig van
beethoven er wurde vor 250 jahren in
bonn geboren
seine kompositionen eroberten die welt
und bonn würde ich den virtuosen mit
einem großen konzert in arbeit ist
beethovens fünfte dirigiert von daniel
barenboim
ein höhepunkt zum 250 geburtstag von
bilthoven ist das jubiläumsjahr durch
corona verhagelt auch barenboim probt
jetzt fürs netz ihm so sagt er sei das
eine ehre
wir designen komponist nicht beschränkt
war und ist in der zeit
er ist ein komponist für die ewigkeit
wenn wir in 50 jahren noch musik leben
haben werden wir sicher weiter weltoffen
spiel hier in bonn ist der geboren der
wohl weltweit meist gespielte komponist
ein eigensinniger kantiger mensch er war
schon früh berühmt und ist ein deutscher
exportschlager geblieben
beethoven ist pure emotionen deshalb
versteht man seine musik auf der ganzen
welt von tokio bis vancouver von sao
paulo bissingen
ein weiterer höhepunkt gestern abend die
beethoven nacht geplant für tausende
live-zuschauer gelandet im netz classic
lang da auch mal ein bisschen anders
[Musik]
hunderte veranstaltungen weltweit sind
ausgefallen
das beethoven jahr wird nun einfach
verlängert dass sie nie auf seinem
sockel würd's nicht stören denn seine
musik ist am ende
zeitlos schön genau so ist es und jetzt
tatar für den sport und norbert mit
einer sportpolitischen entscheidung die
für diskussionen sorgt denn der
internationale sportgerichtshof cas in
lausanne hat die sperre russlands wegen
organisierter doping vertuschung von
vier auf zwei jahre reduziert das heißt
offiziell wird es keine russischen
mannschaften bei den nächsten
olympischen sommer und winterspielen und
der fußball wm geben markus haben in
berlin
was bedeutet dieses urteil konkret in
erster linie streit und diskussionen
denn für viele sportler und experten
geht dieses urteil nicht weit genug
travis tygart chef der us anti doping
behörde spricht sogar von einer
verheerenden entscheidung und guckt man
sich die begründung des cas im detail an
gibt es eine menge hintertürchen für
russland alle unbelasteten sportler
dürfen als so genannte neutrale athleten
aus russland an den start gehen so auch
bei der fußball wm in zwei jahren und
nicht die sportler müssen aufzeigen dass
sie unbelastet sind sondern die wada
muss beweise erbringen
wer nicht sauber ist das wesentlich
komplizierter auch russische funktionäre
und politiker dürfen auf ioc einladung
überall teilnehmen das heißt also das
urteil klingt erst einmal hart lässt
aber russland und vor allem auch dem ioc
reichlich möglichkeiten
markus haben schönen dank für die
erläuterung nach berlin
skiflug weltmeister karl geiger ist drei
tage nach der wm in planica positiv auf
das corona virus getestet worden und
befindet sich in quarantäne der start
des oberstdorf was bei der
vierschanzentournee ist damit gefährdet
vierfach erfolg für norwegens biathleten
beim weltcup sprint in hochfilzen das
für die deutschen starter enttäuschende
rennen über 10 kilometer
gewinnst du lac leid vor drei seiner
kollegen lange gewartet am ende
glücklich über seinen erfolg der
norweger stura heim lage
denn gleich drei seiner teammitglieder
darunter auch der weltcupführende
johannes teenager waren dicht dran am
ende aber nicht schneller fehlerfrei am
schießstand und schnell in der loipe vor
material stimmen derzeit bei den
skandinaviern für die deutschen die
ergebnisse ernüchternd olympiasieger an
peiffer auf rang 22 der beste unter
ihnen es ist das schlechteste ergebnis
seit acht jahren und aus dem letzten
sprint dieses jahres aus gesprintet ich
ja auch für dich ja einfach nur da genau
wer hat bitte so jetzt hände hoch und
zwar vor freude
das gilt für die polizisten in norden
haben ihnen niedersachsen denn die erben
jetzt viel geld 244.000 euro gibt es für
dieses polizeirevier vermacht von einem
dankbaren bürger das geld können die
beamten gut gebrauchen für modernere
möbel eine neue kaffeemaschine und neue
dienstwagen um die zu fassen wie nicht
großzügig geben sondern unrechtmäßig
nehmen
morgen wird ein eher freundlicher und
milder dezembertag den nehmen wir gerne
und sind gespannt auf katja horne
vergleich ich empfehle ihnen wie immer
das heute journal mit dem kollegen claus
kleber um viertel vor zehn und wir hier
sagen danke für das interesse gerne bis
morgen aber erst machen sie sich alle
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]